many people of habits they want to break
and probably some habits other people
want us to change to make those
adjustments habits expert James Clare
says we should think small his popular
blog gets two million visits a month
he's also a frequent speaker at Fortune
500 companies and his work is used by
teens in the NFL Major League Baseball
and NBA clears new book is called atomic
habits an easy and proven way to build
good habits and Greg bad ones
James clear good morning good morning
love this book oh thank you so to help
everyone what are atomic habits sure so
atomic habits was written to be the most
comprehensive guide on how to improve
your habits and I chose the phrase for
three reasons
so the first meaning of the word atomic
is tiny or small and that's a central
part of my philosophy that habits should
be small and easy to do the second
meaning is that atoms are the
fundamental unit in a larger system so
atoms built into molecules molecules
building the compounds and so on and in
a sense habits are kind of like the
atoms of our lives you know like they're
these fundamental units these little
patterns that we repeat and over time
they become more or less our daily
routines the third reason though is that
atomic can also mean the source of
immense energy or power and I think if
you add all three of those together you
understand the narrative arc of the book
which is that if you make changes that
are small and easy to do and layer them
on top of each other like units and a
fundamental system larger system you can
get powerful words okay give a specific
example of how you do that make a small
change in pack it with something you do
regularly without thinking about you say
a 1% change can make exactly yeah that's
right so this idea that habits are I
like to say habits of the compound
interest of self-improvement so this 1%
change you're talking about it's kind of
like imagine you're in a plane and
you're leaving Los Angeles and you're
gonna go to New York I actually
calculated this if you shift the nose of
the airplane just three and a half
degrees it's like seven or eight feet on
the runway you barely even notice it but
you end up in Washington DC it's a New
York and habits are kind of a similar
thing you know they're these small
routines a little 1% changes but as over
time they compound and you can end up at
a very different place based on them and
you say if you're having trouble
changing habits it's not you it's your
system that's right that's interesting
well one of the core philosophies the
book is that we do not rise
level of our goals we fall to the level
of our systems and so often were
ambitious and set these you know lofty
goals for ourselves and we wonder why
doesn't it work out yeah and it's
because we don't have a system behind it
we don't have the habits behind the goal
and also because we set these massive
goals and have no idea to break it down
into its component habits to create that
compound so but give us a concrete
example
I mean waking up in the morning and
exercising the minute you get out of bed
would be one right give us little habits
that people can have put in their lives
that create this bigger change sure well
I mean basically what you do is take
whatever habit you're trying to build
and then scale it down to just a small
thing that you can do within a minute or
two or five so for example if you want
to read 30 books a year scale that down
to read one page and then after you make
your bed in the morning you can put a
book on your pillow so the routine could
be I wake up I make my bed I put a book
on my pillow I take a shower climb in at
night and the book is waiting for you to
read one page same way with that you
know I want to write a book scale it
down to write one sentence or I'd like
to become a meditator scale it down to
meditate for 60 seconds and are you do
you believe in sort of three weeks of a
habit actually locks it in or do you
think that's like how long does it take
to build a habit okay and you'll see all
kinds of things 21 days 30 days there's
one study that 66 days was on average
about how long it took but the honest
answer to how long does it take to build
a habit is forever because once you stop
doing it it's no longer a habit and you
know a lot of people the implicit
assumption behind that question is how
long do I need to work until it's easy
but habits are not a finish line to be
crossed their lifestyle to be lived and
so you need to be looking for these
lifestyle changes something you can
sustain and you stress the importance of
environment saying that it can often
matter more than motivation itself you
write in your book environment is the
invisible hand that shapes human
behavior explain why that's so important
well so many of our habits are just a
reaction to the cues that are in our
environment you know you walk into the
kitchen you see a plate of cookies and
you wanna you don't even have to really
be hungry maybe right yes so that's a
good example I actually did that myself
I used to we would buy apples and
bananas and put them in the crisper in
the fridge and I would never see them
because they were kind of tucked away
then they go bad two weeks later and
they'd have to throw them
and so now we keep them in a display
bowl in the center of the counter and
about sleep we've been teasing all day
about sleep better say how do we make
that a habit so in the book I talk about
these one-time actions that lead to
payoffs again and again so here are a
couple examples for sleep
you can test different mattresses and
then buy the one that gets the best
night's sleep for you you could purchase
blackout curtains so that you sleep in a
room that is dark same thing with like
ear muffs or ear plugs to be you know
reduce noise but then the the last one
in my favorite is you can buy what's
called an outlet timer and an outlet
timer is just a little device on amazon
cost like ten dollars you plug it into
the outlet and then you plug a device
into that timer and one of the things
that you can plug in is a friend of mine
near a all who also wrote a book about
habits called hooked he plugs his
internet router into the timer then he
set it to kill the power attention to me
so Internet's off at 10:00 can't watch
Netflix can't browse the web time to go
to bed and you say your wife is here we
should talk to her about your habits
reprogramming your brain instead of
saying I have to do something say I get
to do something this is a great way I
have to wake up at well so often we go
through life thinking about all the
responsibilities that we have right I
have to take my kids to practice I have
to make dinner tonight yeah and simply
reframing it anything I get to helps you
see the situations in your life as
opportunities rather than burdens James
there's so much good information in here
also about your own personal story
habits helped you change your life it's
really important James clear thank you
so much tonic habits is on sale now and
to complete your own habits scorecard
and contract you gotta sign a contract
visit our website at CBS this morning
calm